Batman the enemy within saw the Riddler
come and go in episode 1 and now Bruce
has to find dr. Harleen Quinzel for
information on a criminal group called
the pact Anthony and Gruber the voice of
the Joker is here to break down the
specifics of episode 2 so what's going
on in Batman the enemy within episode 2
so in the interim times between season
one and season two things have escalated
quite a lot in Gotham City also between
John Doe and Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne has
evolved to become a much more confident
Batman where is the Joker or John Doe as
he's known is finding life on the
outside a little bit difficult to cope
with a bit like a prisoner coming out of
long time being confined he's
overestimated how confident he would
feel on the outside so we see him in
episode 1 of season 2 as much more he's
not doing so well but we find out that
he has fallen in with a group of people
that are sort of nurturing his more
psychotic leanings his biggest drive in
episode 1 is to introduce Bruce Wayne to
his friends the pact of villains and
that is his greatest concern at the
moment seeing his best friend and
wanting to make the introductions to
invite this guy that he's taken into his
confidence into this inner circle of
the rogues gallery what do you think is
the most unique thing about this version
of the Joker this character is conceived
around the same time as Batman and he's
been portrayed so many times in so many
amazing forms in the films and the video
games the anime series comic books and
telltale has done something that even I
didn't as a long lifetime fan didn't see
coming and that's portray him as a nice
guy well to a degree there is an aspect
of him a hidden almost like a
sympathetic gentleness that telltale has
brought out in his character it's
fascinating because for the first time
ever I'm seeing this character as
somebody that you know I think pity is a
strong word but you really see that he
he's tortured much like Bruce Wayne and
I think that's where that dynamic comes
in where he's recognized something
inside Bruce that he recognized inside
himself and that's why he forms that
love at first sight infatuation with
this guy and it's a very interesting
twist to a classic character which yeah
I think is there's a lot of fun to play
Anthony can you tell us about any Easter
eggs that are in the game or any tricks
that the Joker might have up his sleeve
I enjoyed the game I think
Telltale's really stepped up their game
I think people are expecting him to act
a certain way but we're introducing him
really as the option to be a support of
a line should the player want out if the
player wants to see a psychotic
villainous Joker they can go down that
route or if they want to see something
completely different and new
they can befriend this guy and keep him
on site and I think that's really you
know it leads to some very funny moments
like my favorite moments probably the
selfie you know in the in the church
scene it's just so inappropriate but
this perfectly captures that edge over
persona so where does the story go after
episode 2 through the choices of the
player we're gonna go down through two
very different paths will either see the
traditional psychotic clown prince of
crime that the fans have always adored
or through the other option we can see a
brand new and hopefully exciting aspect
to this character and that's buddy Joker
you know the John Doe sympathetic sort
of friend who's really he's got your
back and I think that was the
interesting thing about this guy is that
Joker's always traditionally wanted to
either kill Batman or you know ruin his
life but this John Doe I think would
jump in front of a car for Bruce at
Episode one I think and that's just a
really interesting way to twist this
character so that's what's lurking on
the horizon for the enemy within so be
sure to check out episode 2 on Xbox one
ps4 PC iOS and Android on September 26
see you guys tomorrow bye